hello and welcome to my game development
with python 3 and pygame tutorial series
what i aim to do here is first of all we
want to we're going to use the
programming language of python
specifically python 3. you should be
able to follow along with python 2
and then maybe even some later languages
of python 3.
there might be some minor syntax changes
but for the most part everything should
be
relatively similar
what i like about
python and also pygame and game
development in general with programming
is that you can take
a topic that people find interesting so
a lot of people ask me what what the
first thing they should do when they
program or like how to learn to program
and my question right back to them is
well like what do you want to what do
you want to program and
you have to find something that you're
interested in so for me
i learned a program
learning natural language processing
with the nltk
module with python and i just got like
this big natural language processing you
know pdf book basically
and that worked for me because i was
really interested in that
that's not going to work for most people
because most people don't care about
natural language processing so that's
not going to be a good first topic
but for a lot of people games are a
great first topic because games are fun
and the other thing that's great about
programming games
for education of programming
is because you can visualize the logic
that you code so a lot of times you
can't really visualize what you're doing
but with games you can you can visualize
everything you can visualize the machine
learning or artificial intelligence you
get to visualize the mathematics like
physics and all of that and you get to
visualize your logic you know whether or
not your logic works so i think pi
or well python's a great programming
language for
a new program it's just because the
syntax is really simple but i think
games are also really really great for
teaching people how to program but also
just to kind of hone in on your
programming skills now i realize not
everybody's watching this tutorial uh
brand new to python um so some of you
guys just want to learn how to do pi
game or make games with python now so
this series if you don't know anything
about programming
you can follow this series
might be a little fast pace for you but
if you don't know how some things work
something works then i highly suggest
you just check out the basics tutorial
series for python 3. i have a basic
series for
all the basics of python 3. so if
there's something you're confused about
like a while loop or a for loop check
that out also if you don't already have
python or pygame i'm going to run
through those things really quick
for python
you're going to want to head over here
to python.org head to downloads and
download either python34
um or two seven but uh we're gonna be
using python three
and uh if just for the record if there's
python4 out you'll probably be able to
do it if pi game is supported anyways
any version of python 3 should be fine
though so download that also just if you
are on windows
or any machine that you really want to
preference between 64 and 32-bit
if you have a 64-bit machine you should
definitely choose 64-bit python
so you'll have to go to downloads and
like latest release
and
then go to their downloads page here the
path might be a little different
depending on when you're watching this
but anyways here are like here's your
64-bit release for mac os here's your
64-bit release where is it for windows i
don't see it oh here it is right so you
want to do that
once you have python and first of all
installing python is really simple just
download it and install it and that's it
so you'll have python if you don't have
it next you're going to need pygame and
for pygame we're going to head over to
pygame.org
and we'll go to downloads and here's
where you can download they've got
various things split up you know use the
source if you want to just download the
source and move move it um yourself
windows unix mac
nokia if you want to you can use pi game
on nokia phones
um and then there's also pi game for
android here all kinds of fun stuff so
now keep that in mind
now for me i'm on windows for example so
i would download that also if you are on
windows and you have 64-bit like i just
said you should get
the probably the best thing you can do
is head over to this link that they're
suggesting
and
i've got that up here and it's like this
unofficial windows binaries page and you
can basically get like all of your
packages uh from from here so
um and they're all like windows
installers and a lot of packages don't
come in 64-bit um so you can get them
here so anyway if you're on windows you
can just type in pie game so here's pie
game click on that and then we come down
here and we're 3.4 right now and we want
we only want 64-bit so it would be this
one right here click that download pi
game
and you should have pi game
now once you're all done what you'll
want to do is we'll get out of here and
you should be able to open up a
python command line so you can either
open up this
and see it says your version here and
then whether you're 32 or 64 bit
so you can open up your shell and then
go import and pie game like that
hit enter and make sure you can import
pie game if you can't import pie game
something went wrong um either reinstall
check your installation all that make
sure you matched up 34 and 62 or
32 and 64 bit
also your python version make sure all
that stuff matched up
otherwise if you're still having trouble
leave a comment below and i'll do my
best to help you out so make sure you
can import pygame
and just as an aside
um the kind of environment that i like
to program in is just the straight idle
which is um
interactive development environment
and uh it's actually not really inner
the one i use is not really active but
to get it you would go like if you're on
windows you would just go to start and
then you can find it there
but it's just literally called idle for
python you would click on that so you
can just search for idle oops opened up
python27
so three four open up idle
and come over here it's like this is
interactive so if you said print
hi it's going to immediately output high
and so it's kind of annoying to me to
have an interactive developer
interactive environment so
what we're going to be programming in is
you go here so you open up idle which is
your shell go file new new file and that
opens up a blank document
and from there we can code right so you
can say print you know hi
and you can keep coding and it's not
spitting anything out at you yet and
then you can run it when you're all done
so that's the environment we're to we're
going to program in
and then also to run it you'll have to
save so just go file save as save it as
something whatever it is we want to call
it dot pi whatever
so with that um sorry if that was a
little long-winded for some of you guys
who already have pi game installed and
downloaded and all that but um needed to
cover that just for anybody who doesn't
have that
and now we're ready to actually um
do some basic pie game code so we're not
going to get too in depth in this video
but i just want to show you guys a basic
pie game window and all that so
um
so first we're going to go
import
uh pie game because in order to use pie
game we have to import it
so import pie game and then uh pie game
is like this
it's an instance
um quite literally so what you're going
to need to do is we're going to go pie
game dot init which is initiate
and what this is going to do is it's
going to initiate pie game and all the
modules that come with pie games so
this is basically as necessary as your
import and it needs to be the first
thing you do with pie games so before
you do anything else like
draw a window
or
just anything before you do anything
else you'll have to do import pi game
and pi game dot in it and obviously you
would put your other imports up here if
you if you needed them for those who
don't know with python you download a
module you go import that module there's
a lot of other syntax involved importing
feel free to look that up if you want on
my channel otherwise just know that
we're importing the module here
and this reference is the
initiation function with pi games so you
just it just
it calls the init function so
now uh the next thing we want to do is
we want to set up so all games are in
windows
like a window so to speak so the next
thing we want to do is we want to set up
our windows so
um
and the way that works uh if in just in
case you didn't follow the cancer
tutorial series
windows are actually more like surfaces
okay so or frames so you've got a frame
and then within the frame you have
windows and it's kind of like that with
pi game you've got it's basically your
window is not really a window it's a
surface is what you're going to call it
that's what you think of anyways but you
could have multiple surfaces and stuff
but
for us we're going to keep things really
simple so anyway we're going to say game
display
for our variable and game display is
going to equal pygame dot
display dot set underscore mode
and this is going to be the game's um
width and height basically and width
height or basically the resolution so to
speak of the game
um it has to be supply it's a single
argument so we just we supply it with a
tuple so if you remember your basics a
tuple is defined with um
brackets like this you pretty much have
to because for example we're going to
say our game is 800 by 600 so 800 wide
600 tall
you can also if you remember the basics
a tuple can be one of two things right
you can either do this or you can do it
with
that like this
we won't really get away with it like
this because since we're passing it
through a function it would treat each
of these as a parameter so we want to
put it around brackets so python knows
that hey this is just a tuple as a
parameter
anyway
so this sets our display sets the size
of our display and we're ready to move
on so next
um we go pygame.display.set
underscore caption
and for us what we're going to do is
we're going to make kind of a not really
a racing game we're not racing anything
but we're going to have a little car and
we're going to avoid objects
um i'm going to make the car a race car
and i thought we could call our game a
bit
but a bit racy
now
um
what that's going to do is it just
basically changes the title of the
window so it says caption but it's
really like the window title so right
here python 3.4.1 right would be a bit
racy instead
so
um so that's that next thing that we
want to do is we define uh the game's
clock and what a clock is
is it basically it's going to time
things for us and for our purposes we
use it for frames per second so let's
write this out real quick so we're going
to say clock and that's going to be our
game clock equals pi game dot time
dot capital c clock
and
yeah i don't really want to say too much
more on clock just
besides the fact that it's your it's
your it's your specific game clock so
you could also use
um some sort of timing feature as well
but you definitely want to use clock
because it's basic it's like a it
imposes it on everything uh in the game
so anyway you want to have your own
specific pie game clock
now
um
that basically defines every like major
thing we need to define um but then you
have you know a game and so your game
has what's known as either you've got a
main loop or a game loop is what people
generally call it and everything in that
game loop is where all your logic is
thrown in
and it will change you know basically
what the game looks like and what's
happening so now we want to kind of make
a little game loop here and the only
thing that will break us out of this
game loop that's going on so basically
the game loop is like the logic for your
game
so the only thing that would ever like
stop the game from from running would be
like one of two things either
uh for us since it's a race game we're
going to say the only thing that would
stop us would either be we crashed or we
decided to quit and we close out the
window or something like that so um
the quick command will come later on
that will have something that breaks us
out of the loop at any time but anything
the one thing that will break us out of
the loop every time and it's like part
of the game logic would be if we crashed
so we start the game by saying crashed
equals false so we're saying we have not
crashed right so you start the game you
haven't crashed yet but then if crashed
equals true we need to do something
right we crash so probably going to
reset or something like that
so
uh let me clear this up a little bit so
crashed equals false
and then we're going to say wow
not
crashed so what this asks is wow crash
still equals false basically so if you
said well crashed this would only run if
if you did crash but while not crashed
um basically means exactly what it
sounds like so that's that's why i think
python syntax is so easy it's like a
sentence pretty much but anyway while
not crashed what do we want to do well
we want to like start our loop and at
the beginning of every like loop and
what's nice about pygame is it grabs all
of the events for you in it sort of
helps with event handling so i'll show
you that uh
in a little bit but for now what we're
going to say is what pie game does is it
grabs events so we don't have to like
code any of that so it makes it really
simple on us
so we'll just say for event
in
pygame dot event dot get and what pygame
dot event dot get does is it just gets
any event that happens so that's where
is the mouse on the screen are they
clicking are they pressing keys what key
are they pressing all of that stuff is
um handled by pi game they have the code
that does that for you and what this is
going to do is basically it creates a
list of events that have happened and
this is a list of events per frame per
second right so
generally only one thing's actually
going to happen but you might have
someone moving amounts and clicking at
the same time especially if you have
like a frames like a first person
shooter something like that but
generally it's probably only going to be
one event but anyway
at least for our game it will be uh for
event in pi game.event.get what do we
want to do well for now the only thing
we're going to ask is if the user wants
to quit so we're not going to force them
to keep playing the game forever so
we're going to say if events dot type
equals so double equals so this is a
comparison operator if you just had a
single equal sign that's an assignment
we don't want to assign something to
event.type we're going to ask if it
equals something leave us a double equal
sign
it's a pretty popular place for people
to make typos so make sure you do the
double equals pie game dot and then all
caps quit
and this is something that's handled
within again pi games so for the most
part well at least for our uses
applygame.quit is going to be when
someone hits the x so they x out of the
window
pygame is going to automatically
recognize that as that's a pi game.quit
function basically but then we can we
can ask the
the basically when the person does that
we can handle that right so we could
choose to not close the window if they
hit the x that's
um that's our choice what we want to do
in that scenario we can make it pop up a
message like are you sure you want to
quit stuff like that so
um anyway
or we just don't let them quit
and so pi game got quit and then
what we want to do at this point is we
want to get out of the loop so the first
thing we're going to do is we're going
to say crashed
equals
true so we can break out of this loop
now
we're just doing that for now probably
we might change that code i just want to
show you like how you might break out of
a loop this isn't really the best thing
because otherwise you know you're going
to click this and it's going to run the
crashed
segment basically on us but anyway
crashed equals true for now
and um the other thing i wouldn't mind
us doing is let's go ahead and for event
in pigment.kit we're gonna also print
event so this will just print to console
whatever event is happening um
so so you can just kind of see all of
the events that pygame is tracking on us
and that's basically it now this
will only work for a single frame so we
actually need to keep things keep the
ball rolling
so and actually up until this point all
that's happened is we've pi game dot
init that's fine so we've initiated pi
game we've said okay we want our window
to be you know this size we want our
title to be that um here's how we're
going to measure frames per second
we've not crashed yet
but if we do we'll we'll say pie game
quit and we'll just say we've crashed
we're also going to print the events
that occur
but
uh
with pygame as well as a lot of things
in computer graphics and stuff like this
you first kind of generate the stuff in
the background and then when you're all
done generating everything in the
background you call a command to push it
to the foreground and actually display
it and you'll find that a lot of times
the calculations and everything that's
occurring in the background
unless it's really really you know
complex stuff happening for the most
part even with like complex stuff the
most uh
computationally
taxing event is actually when you go to
display it to a screen that's what
really like takes the most uh processing
so you do all the con like calculations
the moving things around the redrawing
and all this in the background without
actually displaying it and then when
you're all done you'll go to display it
in a brand new frame and so like that
that's just kind of the methodology for
all kinds of things like not only pi
game but also like let's say you're
going to do things in matplotlib for
example same thing you draw everything
first and then when it's all drawn then
you show it okay so anyway that's what
we'll do so after this for loop so for
all the events after we've gathered all
the events and we're printing the event
what do we want to do well we want to
update our display so we're going to say
pygame dot display
dot update
and here's a an important point to note
there's kind of two ways to do this you
can use
pygame.display.update
and
or i guess you not and or but or you
could use pygame.display.flip
okay
and what
pygmy.display.update is going to do is
you can put in a parameter here and it
will just update that one thing so the
background processing uh would be a
little easier
and just pressing in general processing
in general would be easier if you were
to just update us like small things at a
time
but if you do not put any parameter in
there it just updates the entire surface
so again surface you might as well think
of surface as your whole window it's
going to update everything you're seeing
pygame.display.flip on the other hand
will always it doesn't do just a
specific thing it will always just
update the entire surface
i'm personally not certain about why
anybody at least for like 2d games would
ever use anything but
pygame.display.update
um
like why would anybody use
pygame.display.flip when you can do the
same thing with update i'm not too sure
if anybody's watching this i don't know
why they would be
um
watching an introductory video here but
if anybody knows why you would use flip
over display to update empty parameters
let me know because i don't see a
purpose for it
moving on um so we want to update uh the
the screen now and now the next thing we
want to do is we want um we want our
frame to update or we want to like move
the frame on basically so
whenever uh so we've just we've defined
our clock
and now we want to define frames per
second basically how fast are we going
to do this this stuff or basically how
fast are we going to target because
sometimes the calculations might take
too long and we want to actually be able
to achieve the result we want but let's
just say we're going to try
well to do that we can do clock.tick
and then in here
you put the parameter of it sounds kind
of weird that this would be it but
the number you enter here is the frames
per second so if you put 30 that's 30
frames per second if you put 60 that's
60 frames per second but if you want
something to move fast but smooth then
you increase the frames per second so
you'll see more what i mean later on but
if we want to like speed things up we
could just increase the frames per
second that you know go by and that
makes things just move faster
the other thing you can update is just
how fast things move um so you can do
all kinds of stuff and usually updating
how fast things move is usually the
better option because
this frames per second will make sure
you run through this loop the whole loop
that fast so that's going to be far more
taxing on processing
but
anyway i just wanted to cover frames per
second and why um you might use various
numbers
um
now
that's it the only other thing left for
us is when the user wants to quit so
there's a very specific way we need to
exit pie games so just like we have to
initiate pie game we have to like
uninitiate pie game and the way that we
uninitiate pie game is with pie game
dot quit empty parameters
and that will stop pygame from running
and then we can run any other like
quitting function for our program with
python we can just quit with quit empty
parameters
and that's it
so kind of a long intro but if we save
this and we run this
we get our little window here um there's
nothing here but it's a window and you
see our title a bit racy and then here
is all of our events and you'll see if i
put my mouse over the window you see new
events are popping up
and you'll see the same thing we can
also hit keys whoops let's hit the keys
over here and you can see in the
background the keys are being pressed
anyway let me move it over here
see we're pressing keys now and you can
see like the keys are popping up and all
that so that's that and then when we
come over here uh and we hit our x
um that exits the pie game and then we
basically
that was what made the pie game
disappear is this right here and then
we're being asked are you sure you want
to kill the program because we're an
idol this is the way idle works
and that's just the function of the quit
parameter but we'll hit ok
but if you were to say run this game
in our like in the actual pie game
or a python window basically
from the command line there's all of our
events over here and we can press keys
and all that but then when we go to exit
it just exits entirely so that's that's
the purpose of quit but again in idle
it's going to be like are you sure
anyway so that's your
quick quick intro to pie game
we just made a window and all that got a
long way to go
a lot of stuff to explain pie game's
such an
in-depth module it can get confusing
really fast especially like i i still
don't quite understand why you would
call it clock.tick 60.
i guess it's like how many ticks you
want to happen per second i don't know
anyway there's a lot of other
functionalities with pi game and
just making games in general that can
kind of be confusing but we'll get
through it and so anyways that's it for
this one
now if you guys have any questions or
comments on this tutorial video
leave them below be happy to help you
guys out otherwise as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time